à peine ses larmes séchées elles courent
l'épousé et court à toute vitesse est
cool c'est possible dans les gradins
c'est benoît mcginnis bonjour bonjour on
vous a vu dans des grands rôles
hamlet caligula ling ao - claude d'avoir
des centaines de spectateurs chaque soir
mais on me dit que tout jeune vous étiez
plutôt timide explications je te traiter
quelqu'un de super réservés pendant ma
famille puis avec les gens que mes amis
et tout ça mais je te quelqu'un à
l'école et en public assez gêné ça a été
long avant que vous allez faire du
théâtre au secondaire parce que je
croyais pas trop en moi je me devais je
serais capable de faire ce genre de gars
là je faisais rire les jeunes amis
animent été reporté parce que tout le
monde que tout est bon avait pas si je
pourrai mais surtout si c'était pour
être mon métier mais moi je me destinais
à aller travailler comme technicien en
scènes comme régisseur de plateau en
fait sur les aime son pays
samassa m'allume et puis finalement j'ai
pris une option théorbe pissas comme
chargé le reste de ma vie
comment s'est fait le déclic pour le
terme quelle pièce tu as vraiment marqué
au point de dire c'est ça que je veux
faire dans la vie grâce à l'option
théâtre qu'on allait au secondaire on
allait voir des pièces de théâtre
moi j'allais voir du théâtre d'été
raynaud maire quand j'étais jeune on
sortait l'été mais le terreau dans le
cadre de répertoire en saison ça s'est
fait avec
avec l'option théâtre au secondaire et
j'avais vu marie stuart adonis politique
était jouée par sophie faucher puis et
sa mère deux examens histoire c'est j'ai
eu comme une révélation devoir en plus
françoise faucher et sophie et cette
grande pièce intense je suis tout le
monde parler autour de moi puis les tic
au secondaire pas tout le monde qui
coûte mais moi j'ai vraiment été
supérieur captifs par celui des comme je
faire ce genre d'affaires le et ce genre
d'intensité aussi que je voyais sur cinq
est fini par comprendre qu'il n'est pas
nécessaire d'avoir fait quelque chose
pour mourir mais volontaire ça peut être
très exigeant physiquement mais aussi
mentalement parce que des rôles qui ont
marqué oui en fait je me considère comme
quelqu'un d' intenses mais je reste pas
imprégnés de mes personnages à prêter
évidemment quelqu'un on fait là qu on
est dans la pièce l'eau pendant le mois
comment jouer c'est sûr que ça ça c' est
quelque chose qui reste en moi si je
faisais quelque 1000 à ma façon d'être
aussi fort et d'intervenir auprès de
monde sur scène avec nicolette il ya
quelque chose en moi qui étais plus lens
énergie là aussi dans le tour est joué
il ya comme ça allait vite dans ses
berges il aura alors quelqu'un sait
quelque chose de plus léger on dirait
que ça ça lien avec tout un plus plus
libre et tout ce qui l'est du tchad est
amer
moi j'essaie comme acteur répandre le
fait qu'on reste imprégnée avec nous
rôle et ne veut pas c'est un peu un sac
à main mais j'essaie vraiment de me
détacher pas c'est quand même injuste du
théâtre on rattrape et dans quelques
heures ce sera sur la scène du théâtre
du rideau vert incarner l'homme éléphant
cointreau le plus physique
cela dit quand même une massothérapeute
persuaderait par les opérateurs
parce que c'est très exigeant
physiquement ma mère s'est sans doute
sans aucun doute le rôle le plus
difficile que j'ai eu à porter parce que
il ya des rôles émotivement qui sont
vraiment intenses et qui peuvent laisser
certaines traces en nous pendant qu'on
rejoue mais là c est l inverse a été
comme de l'extérieur physiquement ça
s'est mis à s'imprégner dans ma tête et
il fallait vraiment que je me parle que
j'ai pu me motive commencer un
enchaînement et tout ça parce que je
m'en allais prendre une position tordus
qui me fait mal on tire on n'a pas envie
d'aller dans quelque chose qui nous fait
mal
j'aime une folle il faut le porte mon
enfance explique holly ce thriller
indépendant machine à tuer vraiment la
télévision pourquoi parce que ça va
surtout aujourd'hui quand goûter à la
télévision de façon quotidienne comme je
faisais sur tragédie c'est ce qu'est en
train de vie se termine tout d'un coup
tu es mon dieu qu'est-ce qui se passe
mon budget puis aussi le désir d'aller
tourner parce que j'adore c'est donc
c'est un manque ou site et je fais des
blagues en disant que mon budget n'est
pas le même par rapport à vos finances
que j'avais quelque chose à la télé mais
en même temps c'est un vrai plaisir pour
monnet sur un plateau et c'est ça qui me
manque c'est un business merci beaucoup
merci